des frappes d'envergure menées par
l'armée ukrainienne à l'aide de missiles
Aymar d'origine américaine qui est alors
de mon frappé un centre militaire russe
basé à macifica près de Donetsk où était
en attente plusieurs centaines de
soldats
assez rare pour être souligné la Russie
a choisi de reconnaître les faits
qu'elle décrit comme un coup très dur
après une frappe de 4000
sur un centre militaire 63 soldats
russes ont été tués
Kiev de son côté parle de 400 morts et
de 300 blessés et des chiffres
impossibles à vérifier plusieurs
témoignages affirment que l'attaque a
été rendue possible grâce au téléphone
portable des soldats russes qui s'en
servaient pour donner des nouvelles à
leurs proches la Russie elle continue de
bombarder des sites civils à l'aide de
drones une stratégie d'usure dénoncée
par le président Hélène ski seulement
deux jours se sont écoulés depuis le
début de l'année et le nombre de drones
iraniens abattu au-dessus de l'Ukraine a
déjà dépassé les 80 et ce nombre
pourrait augmenter car les nuits
risquent d'être assez difficiles ces
prochaines semaines dans ce qui est
devenu une guerre de position la météo
humide empêche toute avancer sur le
terrain les attaques à distance se
multiplient de chaque côté dans
l'optique d'affaiblir l'ennemi et de
pouvoir se renforcer suffisamment d'ici
le printemps